I want to change I know I need to change
and Beyond just doing better being a
more good than more bad like that's the
only path that's like in my head and I I
I I feel trapped he doesn't have to fall
in love with himself right out of the
gate right that takes a long time to
turn the corner um he doesn't even have
to like himself out of the gate Eric has
to believe he's worth being well my goal
for you my dream for you and it's going
to sound insane my dream for you is
peace because here's what's going to
happen um you'll have a kid and there
will be a complication or mom will get
sick at some point life will happen and
so it doesn't inoculate you from those
things but it does give you a foundation
that you've never experienced before so
that you can be whole when those things
hit